Varys: Aegon the Unworthy legitimized all
of his bastards on his deathbed.
Inevitably, the greatest of these, Daemon
Blackfyre, declared himself the rightful heir
and ignited yet another war for the crown.
After much bloodshed, Daemon was killed by
an alliance of his half-brothers on the Redgrass
Field.
All the same, his descendants continued to
threaten the Targaryens until half a century
later, when Barristan the Bold slew Maelys
the Monstrous on the Stepstones, extinguishing
Daemon's line.
Aegon, the Fourth of His Name, is remembered
by history as "The Unworthy".
Quite a feat considering the other kings of
Westeros.
But even in a family not known for equanimity,
Aegon stands out for spiteful incompetence.
He tore apart the realm simply because he
couldn't rule himself, much less Westeros.
As a young prince, Aegon's wit made him beloved
at court and won him forgiveness for youthful
indiscretions, but the cold steel of the Iron
Throne didn't temper his passions.
King Aegon proclaimed that if he had to spend
his days being pricked by a thousand swords,
he'd spend his nights pricking others with
his one.
Lords sent their daughters from court so they
would not catch the king's eye whilst other
lords summoned their daughters to court so
they would.
The only woman in whom he took no pleasure
was his sister and wife Naerys, even after
she gave him a son and heir, Daeron.
Perhaps Aegon was jealous of her supposed
love for his brother, the legendary hero Prince
Aemon the Dragonknight.
Aegon was most certainly jealous of him.
Not of his bravery or honor, but how young
maidens swooned and cried at the songs about
him.
But most likely, Aegon disregarded his wife
and son because he chafed at restraints of
any kind.
Be they the bonds of marriage or patrimony
or even reason.
When Prince Daeron objected to his father's
foolish plan to invade Dorne, Aegon incited
a lickspittle lord to accuse the queen of
adultery with Aemon, making Daeron illegitimate.
Prince Aemon defended the queen's honor in
trial by combat.
But while the lord's claim publicly died with
him, no sword can kill a rumor.
Out of spite and pique, Aegon had seeded doubt
into his own heir's claim to the throne, which
bore bitter fruit with the birth of another
son, the bastard Daemon Waters, by the king's
own cousin.
Raised in the Red Keep on account of his mother's
royal blood, Daemon grew tall and powerful
and excelled at all the marshal skills that
men wrongly value in leaders.
Instead of protecting his own heir from a
rival, Aegon knighted Daemon at twelve and
shocked the realm by bestowing on him the
Conqueror's own Valyrian steel sword.
He even let the boy renounce his common bastard's
name and take the Targaryen sword's name for
his own, becoming Daemon Blackfyre.
Still, though a name can change, blood can't.
And Daeron was Aegon's only trueborn son.
Until he wasn't.
On his deathbed, Aegon forever earnt his epithet
by legitimizing all his bastards, from the
baseborn sons to the great bastards of noble
ladies, including Daemon.
Fittingly, Aegon's last act was to thrust
himself into the realm and seed chaos.
A Targaryen without self-restraint may have
led Westeros to the brink of ruin, but the
highborn pushed it over.
Though Daeron governed justly and wisely,
correcting the worst excesses of his father's
rule, many lords had grown rich off these
excesses and did not approve of Daeron's reforms,
particularly the peace he'd struck with Dorne.
The malcontents rallied to Daemon and whispered
that he should be king instead of his brother,
whom, thanks to Aegon, many suspected was
a bastard.
At first, Daemon indulged these lords out
of courtesy and vanity.
But over time, their grievances and flattery
wore down his objections, along with any sense
of obligation to the half-brother who had
granted him lands and a wife.
Daemon agreed to claim the throne by right
of birth and, more importantly, arms.
A wheel with two hubs will not turn, and a
kingdom with two kings will burn, as the saying
goes.
Not that such a cost stopped anyone with even
the remotest claim and opportunity, much less
House Blackfyre.
Their rebellions consumed tens of years and
thousands of lives.
First Daemon's own, then his son, Daemon the
Second, who reigned for a night.
Then another son, Haegon, crowned by Bittersteel,
another legitimized bastard who had founded
the Golden Company to support the Blackfyre
claim.
When Haegon was executed, Bittersteel crowned
Haegon's elder son Daemon the Third, who,
in turn, was slain by the Lord Commander of
the Kingsguard, Ser Duncan the Tall.
Finally, Maelys the Monstrous fell to Ser
Barristan Selmy in the War of the Ninepenny
Kings, and the Blackfyre Rebellion ended with
the extinction of the entire line.
As is appropriate.
Fire is only black when it is burned to ash.
Perhaps that was the true problem with the
Targaryens.
The blood of the dragon runs hot and fire
consumes.
Perhaps what Westeros needs is a ruler born
not from fire, but from snow.
Jorah Mormont: Aegon Targaryen's Blackfyre
and Visenya's Dark Sister disappeared in Daemon
Blackfyre's rebellion.
Ellaria Sand: A simple word for a simple act.
And so, of course, men complicate it.
A child born to a wife is a gift from the
gods.
A child born to a mistress or an obedient
servant girl is a bastard, unworthy of its
father's name.
So instead they call the children after the
land where they were born: "Flowers" in the
Reach and "Hill" in the Westerlands, "Stone"
in the Vale and "Storm" in the Stormlands,
"Rivers" in the Riverlands and "Waters" in
the Crownlands, "Pyke" in the Iron Islands,
"Snow" in The North, and in Dorne "Sand".
By these names, everyone can recognize a bastard,
even if his own father won't.
Though sometimes a father with too much gold
and daughters will ask the king to legitimize
a bastard son and give him his family name.
If his wife objects, the next one does not.
But sometimes the gods play their jokes and
later his wife will give him a trueborn son
of their own.
When this happens, well, children die all
the time, so do fathers.
Even the beautiful Targaryens had bastards
when brothers tired of their sisters.
Many took the name Blackfyre after the Conqueror's
own sword.
When Aegon the Unworthy legitimized all his
bastards on his deathbed, they rose up against
his trueborn heir.
Westeros bled, Dorne yawned.
For most of Westeros, the Blackfyre Rebellion
only proved what they already knew.
Bastards are treacherous, born of lust and
shame.
But in Dorne, lust is not shameful.
They know that bastardy does not make a man
more treacherous than another.
Man does not need the help.
Bronn: Most boys dream of becoming a Kingsguard.
Rich boys from good families get the chance.
Smart boys stay at home and sing songs about
them instead, opening purses and thighs, because
the Kingsguard isn't really good for much
else.
Prince Aemon the Dragonknight may be the most
famous Kingsguard who ever lived.
How did he die?
Defending Aegon the Unworthy from the brothers
of a man whom Aegon fed to his dogs.
The man's crime?
Sleeping with one of the many mistresses Aegon
wasn't using, and the man was one of Aegon's
own Kingsguard.
Jaime Lannister: Prince Aemon the Dragonknight,
who wielded the Valyrian sword Dark Sister.
He died defending King Aegon the Unworthy
from assassins, though the king had insulted
Aemon throughout his reign and had well earned
his fate because Prince Aemon had sworn our
oath.
Beside the name of Ser Gwayne Corbray, who
dueled the Targaryen bastard Daemon Blackfyre
for an hour during the Battle of Redgrass
Field though outmatched and grievously wounded,
because Ser Gwayne had sworn our oath.
Viserys Targaryen: But even without our dragons,
we were still the blood of Old Valyria, which
proved just as dangerous.
One of my foolish ancestors didn't see what
separated his bastards from our family proper
and legitimized them all on his deathbed.
Adopting the name "Blackfyre," the bastards
proved their nature and tried to seize their
father's kingdom.
And when they failed, their sons tried.
When their sons failed, their grandsons tried.
Until finally, Ser Barristan the Bold, Knight
of the Kingsguard, slew Maelys the Monstrous
in the War of the Ninepenny Kings, ending
the last of the Blackfyre line.
Ultimately, without our dragons and with our
blood diluted by commoners, we failed to see
the greatest threat growing under our noses.